okay Amanda we just had a picture in of
the reporter who has been shot Alison
Parker she was shot alongside her
cameraman Alison Parker we've got a
tweet here from Cameron Oh Austin he
tweeted around five or six minutes to
get home to say that Alison Parker was a
J mu grad and Adam presumably the
cameraman was a Virginia Tech grad he
said I worked beside both of them the
nicest people you could meet just in
shock and I guess that pretty much sums
it up doesn't it Amanda reporters in
America do you go into these dangerous
situations a lot of rioting been
happening across the states with various
different reasons recently but this is
just a reporter and a cameraman out on
what seemed a routine report yeah there
have been some very high-level risky
situations with riots and the likes of
Ferguson over the past months and
thankfully it hasn't resulted in a loss
of life in those sometimes very tense
situation so the fact that this was
certainly something far more laid back
in terms of the way they were delivering
their news piece this morning at 6:45 it
had a very light tone about it and the
police said that there was certainly no
risk in terms of what they were doing
they wouldn't have felt any danger going
into a situation that was in a safe area
and that was talking about you know
something that was relatively not
trivial but certainly not anything
contentious not anything controversial
and then for this to happen you see
their reaction and obviously hearing the
shots was one of shock and this is the
newsroom trying to really come to terms
with what has happened here to two of
their members of staff and I did speak
to the newsroom to try and get more
information about what had happened and
I asked them you know how are they and
this was at the point where it hadn't
been confirmed that both of them had
been killed and there was a very lengthy
silence and I got the impression that
they knew at that point how they were
and that the tragedy had happened and
obviously that's going to be incredibly
difficult for them to come to terms with
in a situation where it was just their
morning news show and the last thing
they would be expecting in a very safe
environment is for two of their staff to
journalists of video
and a reporter to be killed in this
shooting the person who fired those
shots hasn't been found yet this will be
a huge police operation as that news
comes out that two people have been
killed during a live broadcast as they
were just doing their jobs as part of
the morning news show